it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes that's a great story let's make it
up later guys welcome to movie fights
oh yeah movie fights where two
competitors clash over it's a battle of
wits and opinions and they do it all
while standing for nearly an hour can
you believe it excited to be back for
movie fights the all new movie fights if
your rejoining us for the first time
then we have a whole new format we have
three judges I'm one of the judges and
then we have two judges over there
they'll break down exactly how that
works let me introduce the man the myth
the legend mr. dan merle thank you now
dan you're gonna be handling some facts
and whatnot i will be checking the facts
and i will be judging based on the
factual arguments and form style
technique any number of things and also
just my opinion I flip the coin really
that is the secret to your wisdom yeah
all comes from the coin
thank you Dan Morell for being here as
always and oh sit and write next year
another damp Danielle Radford that's my
name hey tell us how your thing works
with the computer and whatnot okay
computers and so the weight of this
works is I'm going to be checking the
pull on YouTube not Twitter I'm gonna be
checking the pull on YouTube if you
don't see the polls wait until you see
that little gear up here up in your
upper right hand part of your screen
click that you can like turn annotations
on and off and it'll show you the poll
and you can click there and vote on the
poll now the way that is going to work
is that if there needs to be a
tiebreaker vote that's y'all well that's
a break ties oh ho ho you breakers have
chains
nice and Danielle don't forget to tell
us if you come across any sick memes
oh you know I only bring them dankmemes
okay mean to you how keep them dank
thank you so again I'm going to judge
Dan's gonna judge and if we are locked
up at one one then we go to you the
audience to decide who wins can you
believe it who wins who decides oh my
god let's meet our competitors
you know this man you love him he is my
biological father and he holds the
record for most quotes on the back of
DVD boxes according to Guinness Book of
World Records Dan may be fact check that
I just made that up actually but you
quote oh you have a lot of movie quotes
out there Scott man I'm proud of some of
them not so much like I was actually
quoted I think on the box for not the
box but the ad for the Love Guru yes yes
Mike Meyers infamous I was wasted when I
saw it is it too late to rebook movie
fights no I would love having you here
thanks for coming back my son and oh you
know she's one of our favorite youtubers
Oh old friend of the family Jenny
Nicholson Jenny I'm Louie the e stands
for everything everything stands for
Elaine Oh does it yes your parents were
big Seinfeld fans oh yeah
cuz you were born like post science I
don't even get that reference right way
to keep it way to keep it millennial
Jenny Nicholson that's my brand ice you
know I'm so psyched I never I don't even
know what that I don't know what the
master might be counts I'll forget it
forget that's a you know what that was a
delightful bit jte roll that back
[Music]
hell yes so again two fighters there is
three regular round questions and then
we go to the four questions speed round
the first fighter to achieve four points
will be crowned our winner and the other
fighter will go home a loser but a
friend sorry I'm very excited for this
are you guys excited so sir it's a fight
okay round 1 Star Wars the last Jedi
great or not great Wow
we're gonna settle it right here right
now and let's start off with our man
Scott Mills okay oh you're starting with
the not great argument I'm gonna go with
not great with a capital N and a capital
G not great Star Wars the last Jedi is
my seventh favorite Star Wars movie
after on my list Revenge of the Sith yes
I actually liked a prequel more than the
last Jedi and here's why I thought it
was boring it was too long the pacing
was a problem it felt disjointed you
have thin and rows and this relationship
didn't work there was no chemistry
between Kelly Marie Tran and John boyega
I at the stuff with Luke I liked seeing
Luke back in Mark Hamill back as Luke
Skywalker but I felt that that for what
Luke stood for in the original trilogy
was betrayed by this film it felt very
clichéd that he was sort of living as a
reckless overall the whole movie felt
like just it's been it felt nothing
nothing was imaginative about the last
Jedi I get that they tried to shake
things up a little bit Rian Johnson
tried to shake things up by you know
killing off Luke in the spoiler order
and and doing some other changes but by
the end of the last Jedi I didn't really
feel excited about seeing where episode
9 was gonna go at the end of the force
awakens which is a much better made film
even though it's basically a Reaper
or a rehash of a new hope but it's still
better made as a film it just flowed
better it felt like a stronger movie
whereas the last Jedi it felt like it
was all over the place it didn't really
flow it was slow the pacing was an issue
and in the end the last Jedi was a major
disappointment okay you say not great
Jenny Wow I see it's great I really
liked the way it felt different from the
force awakens I think that I would
disagree that the plot is disjointed I
think that every scene fits in with the
theme of the film I think that Finn and
ROS the point of their entire subplot
was it was maybe the best illustration
of the theme of the film which is the
potential for failure for letting
yourself down for learning from your
mistakes and I think that also ties in
with Luke Skywalker I know a lot of
people were disappointed because they
think that he was like a failure they
didn't like to see him be trained his
old ideals but I think it's so important
that he does that because it lets him be
more of a character I think that seeing
Luke's struggle with the dark side which
is basically what we've seen every Jedi
character do and every major Star Wars
story v definitely holds true to the
rest of the series but like you
mentioned there were things done there
to shake it up I thought the fact that
they killed Snoke the fact that Luke
died this connection between the
protagonist and the villain is something
we haven't really seen in Star Wars
before and that's what made me really
excited for episode 9 I can't wait to
see where the characters go the first
order has been totally shaken up by the
fact that the entire order of it is
thrown out of whack we have Huck's and
kylo hating each other I think there are
a lot of different directions that can
go for the next one that doesn't just
feel set up in a straight line which is
what I like about it so much great fight
it out you two okay now Channy a
nicholson the e stands for Elaine okay
I'm Seinfeld
so from scythe oh but you never saw
which I respect got a few old but here's
the thing you talk about killing Snoke
again spoiler alert sorry if you didn't
see the movie but you should have pie
now because it did make 1.3 billion
dollars worldwide but here's the thing
Jenny and here's the thing my son is
that Snoke was not an interesting
character to begin with he was a poor
man's Emperor a lot of things that were
set up in the force awakens felt
a rehash of the original trilogy well
see that's the complaint everyone had
when it came out they were saying it was
a rehash and at the time I was saying
it's a rehash because they're setting it
up so that they can trick you in the
next one so they introduced all these
familiar things that feel almost trophy
and then I was like I bet the next movie
is gonna totally turn those on their
head and they did Snoke died Snoke we
were supposed to think he was important
and he wasn't just because the movie
fooled you doesn't mean that but Snoke
was not in it he was like the emperor in
the original trilogy like I was actually
scared of that guy you know everything
about force awakens so was just as
powerful but here's the thing so so you
get to the end of Return of the Jedi
where they've sacrificed so much to
destroy the Empire and then just thirty
years later the Empire Strikes Back
again just thirty years not three
hundred years all it took was thirty
years for this new new Empire whatever
you want to call them you know it's just
the Emperor's New Clothes the dark side
though sure yes it was only thirty years
and they already have enough firepower
to build a Death Star that's the big
size of a planet well thy mistake in the
original trilogy was they thought they
could just defeat the dark side they're
like oh well just kill all of them and
it's better
and what this trilogy is kind of
demonstrating is that the dark side is
going to keep coming back because it's
part of the force you need to find a
balance but here's the thing there was
also the humor aspect of it like you
know like jokes in your Star Wars I do
like jokes in Star Wars but not when
they intrude on the bigger message and
not when they intrude on the suspense
and the intensity and the action you
have any examples of that yes the
beginning of the film when Ray goes to
give Luke the lightsaber and he looks at
he throws it over his shoulder I mean
yeah people laughed at it but it didn't
feel if I felt like it diffused the full
pound Jenny what did you think of that
scene that movie the best time to have
humor is the beginning of the film I
think it would be kind of weird if they
were cracking jokes and like the
praetorian guard fight but I think the
beginning is when you want to have
characters interacting and kind of a
comedic light-hearted way so you can see
more of a connection between Luke and
Rey and how they let me ask you a
question that fans were asking do you
feel like that that lowered the impact
and the significance of the force and
the lightsaber for Lucas just throw it
over shoulder like that I don't think so
like it was unexpected I like that it
was unexpected and I laughed for a
second because of a you know the timing
of it but then when I thought about I
went wait that's not what I want from a
Star Wars movie well I wanted something
that was going to build on its
predecessor like the way the Empire
Strikes Back built upon the new hope in
every way shape or form which is why the
Empire Strikes Back
is still not only the best Star Wars
movie by far but it's one of the
greatest movies ever made I'm really the
only Star Wars film outside of the
original that transcends the genre and
the franchise the for the last Jedi I
don't think it did that I thought it was
a step down from from from the force
awakens and of these last three movies
just for the record that includes also
rope one one road one I think it's the
best movie of these last three oh my god
yes I know in the minority on this but
again this is about the power of the
argument not about the choice and the
power of the argument is a by the end
but I got to the end of okay this is
important this is very very important
when I got to the end that the force
awakens I was like okay it was good
enough I get if they played it safe I
can't wait to see what happens next when
I got to the end of rogue one which for
the first hour was a little dull but the
second hour was fantastic and the way it
snapped right into a new hope I wanted
to run right home and watch a new hope I
was so pumped I was so jazzed in the way
that road one was a very very awesome
fanservice movie it worked well when I
got to the end of the last Jedi I
literally went so that's it like but not
only do I not do I not really know
what's gonna happen next I can't really
like figure it out but I don't even care
and that says a lot because I like any
of the characters in the new trilogy I
thought that I thought that Rey was the
best character kylo Ren was kind of a
[ __ ] just like he was in the first
movie but sorry am i have to say [ __ ]
on the air no way Carlsen last week you
this week no bait
I first of all the scene between when
when kylo and Ray are talking to each
other you know like they're having like
this FaceTime chat and they're in the
force um it was so cheesy
what do you say to that I mean it's it's
kind of run supposed to be vader look
not i think saying that he's not scary
enough because he's like a wuss or
something i think that's such a
self-defeating argument because he's not
trying to be vader i think if anything
Snoke was like our Vader he was our big
scary guy I think what's more
interesting as a villain whose
personality you care about for me for
kylo Ren I care about his Redemption arc
his mom is still alive he still has
family that loves him and cares about
him and it seems like turning him back
is gonna be the way to defeat him so
maybe if the little thing of the new
trilogy was like oh I hope Rey can go
cut his head off then maybe I would care
more if he seemed more physically
powerful and and just a big frightening
mustache twirling bad guy but I think
that would be kind of a layman to the
trilogy of like oh she got him oh he was
like Darth Maul he moved so fast
okay Jenny Nicholson here's the thing
okay all right Jenny Nicholson so I just
love that Jenny Nicholson um here's the
thing
so not only okay I see your point and I
respect your opinion but I'm not I
didn't feel it I've seen a movie three
times now and I thought okay maybe I'll
like it better the second time
I didn't maybe I'll like it more the
third time I didn't I'm just not
grabbing it and Snoke is no Darth Vader
either he's not even close
Darth Vader is one of the greatest movie
villains of all time
and snow can definitely kylo Ren don't
come near Vader I mean maybe they're not
trying to supposed to be and I think the
whole point is that kylo Ren is no Vader
he never will be that's why he's such a
spoiled brat that's how he comes across
that's not medicine your only Jerry knew
movie is that it's not the old movie and
that's from that I think that's
self-defeating I think it's trying to be
something different but what is it what
is it trying to be it's trying to be a
family adventure story that continues
the theme set up in the first two
trilogies it's almost a midpoint between
the two because you have the prequel
trilogy where it's
someone turning to the dark side the
original trilogy which is about someone
turning back to the light and then this
one which seems to be about two major
characters meeting in the middle
to balance the force once and for all it
just seems like the matically it's a
good continuation Scott said its seventh
on his list where do you rank it your
pantheon of stars it's hard to rank them
I don't usually rank movies just because
I feel like they're all very different I
have ones that I like and that I don't
like but there are such different
strengths across them I don't usually
rank them here's the other problem I
have with the last Jedi general Hawkes
you don't like general I don't like that
character at all
talk about a [ __ ] my god but why is
that a drink of water it's a joke but
why is then I'll say emasculated
character I'm a bad character why does
that not work as a villain because
because you have to have a villain that
people are going to fear it is
established at the beginning of the last
Jedi that general Hawkes is a joke when
he's talking to Poe and he's trying to
be menacing and nobody on the bridge of
that Star Destroyer no one is taking him
seriously and yet yo mod healed the
whole resistance successfully he has the
firepower he has the troops I almost
find it more frightening that he's this
frustrated kind of Napoleon complex
figure where he feels he has something
to prove that makes him more dangerous
to me especially now that he feels like
he's been put down by kylo Ren you had
that last significant look from him at
the end of the movie where he's looking
after where kylo is gone with this
expression of pure hatred and you're
like oh there's gonna be infighting in
the next one I have a question for both
you guys we touched on that with the the
lightsaber the throwing of the
lightsaber how do you respond to people
who say there are sacred things within
Star Wars that this movie violated I'll
start with Scott okay now I am all for
shaking it up if it goes in the right
direction obviously I'm gonna go back to
the original trilogy and I'm not gonna
look at the way that Empire Strikes Back
really shook things up with repeatedly
by the way by by putting a major
character in in carbonite you know 2/3
of the way through the movie by by
taking your hero and or and your villain
and and taking this Universal battle
between good and evil and making it very
personal with one of the
greatest plot twists and movie surprises
in the history of moviemaking and that's
how you shake it up
I mean empires violate anything sacred
it doesn't violate I mean they were
still they were still formulating things
so you know you know I always argue that
Empire was only the second movie and
there wasn't a whole lot to really like
shake up and and and betray but by the
eighth film or the ninth if you include
rope one which you should because it is
a Star Wars story yes it's in the night
your mccabe with shaking things up i'm
okay with killing off a main character
and then another main character if it if
it means something if it has an
emotional impact if it stirs you and it
feels right the killing of Snoke didn't
do anything for me like when Luke sort
of passed away and moved on to the
wherever they all go when they when they
die they go to be one with the force
just a correction they go where okay so
when Luke want to be one with the force
I just felt like oh okay so after all
that you know gotcha so you are unmoved
Jenny talk about the the sacred nature
of some of those things and the shakeups
yeah and how are you affected by them I
would say I don't really think there's
anything sacred in Star Wars I would say
if we want to talk about things that
have maybe ruined past things that were
established the prequels have done more
for that than the new trilogy has I mean
introducing midi-chlorians this idea
that Anakin Skywalker was some kind of
Jesus virgin birth conceived by the
force that kind of mysticism on what had
been at the whole just kind of a
grounded family story with this space
wizardry thrown in made it very high
fantasy and kind of altered the genre
and I view the sequel trilogy as
bringing it back to the original genre
that we saw in the first trilogy gotcha
how are you affected by those big
moments by I was affected by them I was
I mean I really enjoyed my viewing
experience every time I see it I don't
understand the people that aren't moved
by the character arcs I like all the new
characters I like where they've taken
the old ones papillae is still alive and
I thought that was a great send-off for
Luke it was on his own terms it
suggested he's going to come back as a
force ghost
he got to demonstrate a display of power
before he left time we're gonna call it
there Wow Wow Jimmy nickles this is the
argument that is setting the internet on
fire so we're gonna decide it once and
for all we are deciding it once and for
all and you guys came at this with very
different perspectives and you each had
a lot of great points I mean Jenny you
had some really interesting stuff about
the themes within this movie and the
themes within each trilogy that were
real eyeopener's and but then Scott you
came at it with just a lot of
interesting perspective the length of
the movie the relationships didn't
resonate for you
characters betraying what they'd been
set up to do but I felt like Jenny
countered a lot of that by dissecting
the complexity of some of these
characters and the complexity of some of
these relationships and saying it's you
know just because it's different doesn't
mean it's so off-brand for Star Wars and
I mean you this was super difficult as
difficult as blowing up a Death Star but
I got the Death Star's actually play the
game play the game but at the end of the
day just your vision of the complexity
of those characters the way you broke
down a villain that's lacking in certain
things and wants to get that revenge it
makes sense for his motivations I got to
go know we have three boats here and we
go to mr. Dan Merle yeah the way that I
saw this argument overall was it's two
different styles of fighting which makes
it difficult to judge I felt like Scott
was if you're going to the boxing
metaphor he's stolen body body blows and
Jenny was throwing back with haymakers
absolutely what won the fight was that
the little body blows or was it the
haymakers and you know it was a good
back and forth
the thing that swayed me to one side was
and I thought it was a really well put
argument was and it also countered the
other side very well many of their
points was when you know Scott kind of
brought a lot of original trilogy points
to the table and thinks it didn't quite
add up to him and Jenny's response was
that you know the prequel trilogy was
one thing and the the middle trilogy was
this one and this one seems to be going
this way I thought that was a good kind
of summation of her position and I feel
like Scott made so many different points
but they never kind of coalesced for me
into one big argument and I felt like
Ginny was able to do that better so I'm
gonna have to go with Jenny Jenny Jenny
the point let's talk to Danielle Radford
and see just four okay so going from
again going from the YouTube poll yes
I'm as of right now who pretty
overwhelming Jenny you won with 71%
while manse had 28% of funny things that
I found online Sibley's I saw you and
Dan cracking up over there I might call
that was super funny yeah
so come on Twitter jack underscore D
underscore man hi I'm wrote I'm
concerned can how really be an impartial
judge considering one of the fighters is
his time displaced future self before
the show is over I'm gonna have to close
the loop people make some really great
general cox jokes and also guys friends
friends guys friends i love you
we do know the way you got it knuckles
is a dead meat my mom knows it stop
sending me you've got it knuckles Thank
You Danielle Wow
so Jenny you are up 1-0 gotta be change
good times let's see question numero dos
don'ts what was the biggest snub from
the 2018 Oscar nominations so of all the
nominations all categories what was the
biggest snub Jenny Nicholson we're gonna
start with you this time
okay well I only looked at one category
to prepare for this but I decided that
the Justice League was cruelly snubbed
in the special effects category okay a
follow-up question what the what now
[Laughter]
please let us in on your opening
argument um I really felt for that team
it's kind of like an underdog sports
movie they have that one coming out with
the volleyball coach that dies right
before the team goes to Nationals and
they're like we have to win it's very
inspiring I don't know if you've seen
the trailer I feel like the Justice
League is that team from that volleyball
movie they had to lose their initial
director and then totally change
stylistically to the Whedon verse so
they basically had to recolor eyes and
tire shots if you look at the trailer
versus the new movie that whole fight
with Superman happened in like the
daytime in the movie and in the trailer
it happened at like whatever blue dusk
happens in all Snyder movies that non
descript time of day when everything's
all d saturated and blue like it's
midnight but also High Noon just a weird
on the horizon they had to change all
that and make it look like a real movie
again and they also had to remove the
mustache from Henry Cavill and that's
really the special effects team becoming
an actor it's almost like the mocap in
Planet of the Apes they're doing a lot
of heavy lifting there because the upper
lip is such a large component of a
performance when you're portraying it I
don't know why I'm hearing laughs but
yeah that was my reasoning I feel like
they really contributed to his
performance and really changed the movie
for the better okay so the Justice
League the effects team
yes applause from the peanut gallery
Scott manse what is the one biggest 2018
Oscar snub what is a snub what is to be
or not to be what is a snub a snub jenia
Nicholson is something that really was
screaming to be nominated because it
deserved to be nominated because it was
so good whether it's a film or
performance or a director something that
everybody or at least most people were
behind as saying boy this was awesome
this was fantastic
this is going to get nominated and then
it doesn't and it should have and it's
surprising when it doesn't
that's a snub yeah and that is why for
Best Picture by the way if this question
was give us the best definition of snow
I would continue I see that's a part of
my argument because when this movie did
not get nominated for Best Picture after
it was getting raves all year long and
it was so good and layered and had depth
and heart and humor of a quotable movie
of the great romantic comedy that movie
is the big SiC that should have been
nominated for Best Picture because it is
a great movie that worked on so many
levels it was clever it was smart it was
funny it had heart it's based on a true
story the writers of the film it's their
story and Kumail Nanjiani got to play
himself and Zoe Kazan got to play Emily
Gordon and it was it was really smart in
the way it deconstructed cultural
barriers going across Pakistan in the
USA and perceptions and stereotyping and
that 9/11 joke that I command on Johnny
uses to defuse the question from Ray
Romano and Holly Hunter about what's
your take on 9/11 that was hilarious and
it was the first time in let's see what
is it 17 years almost 17 years since
9/11 that anybody was able to actually
laugh at a joke that had 9/11 and why
did they laugh
it was okay to do so because it was a it
was a smart response to a stupid
question the movie is very quotable it
should have been nominated it wasn't and
it's a massive massive snub all right
we've got two answers let's slug it out
you all slug it out with words well I
agree with you
thank you but but but snobs I think who
needs this win more Kumail
everyone loves his movie I do feel bad
for him on the drive here today I saw a
billboard for your consideration Best
Picture and I was like that's right he
deserves that right that's right but
thank you look at the crew that worked
on Justice League
they were just thrown this pile of
scenes they were probably slogging away
in dark musty cubicles with Snyder
hanging over their shoulders and then
one day we even walks in and we all know
what he's like I've heard a couple of
things so suddenly they're dealing with
Whedon and they had to change everything
around suddenly it's a comedy they had
all those shots that were clearly
pickups where the characters suddenly
tell a joke and then Whedon probably
brought that in and in some kind of
wicker basket and said assimilate this
into the movie so I'm like this yeah
assimilate this they're all on cassette
tapes and this team had to plug them in
to their computer devices however you
edit a movie and and make it a movie and
most people that watched it thought it
was okay
and to me that's a victory but watch any
wait a minute just a minute just a
minute it is their job to do that
everybody got to have a wife but but
everybody that's what I guess literally
was I guess it literally was like they
got they got funding for the big stick
it's a tax write-off now pictures were
in the credits so it's a tax all right
so Domino's literally Kamau's job to
write and act in the movie play
it is the editors job to make a movie
that is so seamless that people watching
are not going to notice how well it is
because it flows so seamlessly I Tonya
was a tremendous achievement in editing
because of the way that movie was cut
and edited and that should have been
nominated for Best Picture - I mean that
was movie I was actually going to go
with but I went with the big sick
because I felt like the big sick is a
film that was it's it is one of the best
romantic comedies of the last 30 years
up there with When Harry Met Sally Jerry
Maguire 500 days of summer why are you
laughing
what is so funny I mean but okay totally
off track here but do you think I don't
think what it like in I come back to the
word - the definition of a snub
something that everyone goes holy [ __ ]
this movie's gotta get nominated this
performance has to get nominated people
are not going going looking at Justice
League and going like holy [ __ ]
that movie has to get nominated for
editing you are but most people are not
the expectation going into the Oscars
the predictions a lot of them were that
the big sick could and should get
nominated for Best Picture and when it
wasn't it was an omission that made it a
snob justice leave not getting nominated
for editing doesn't qualify as a snob
VFX VFX you're contending a China
nominative he did he did sway me in that
a little bit that I Tania deserves the
not more than the big sick 100% I'm
gonna come back to you with a specific
question tell us why the big sick is
more deserving than films like I Tanya
Florida Project Logan Blade Runner 20 49
other films that people say got snuffed
the big sick more important than okay
and and the big sick was an omission
because and I saw that as an omission
for the same reason that I was very very
happy that get out got nominated because
it was more than just a movie there was
something else going on behind the
entertainment value it was entertaining
and it was very well done very well
written I'm talking about big sick that
I and and some of those other films that
you name by the way I believe water was
awesome I [ __ ] love play one or 2049
and I love itaya I've seen a movie four
times it gets better the more I see it
because the way it's made you pick up
more stuff out of it but with with the
big sick I just felt that there was
something to be said about the movie the
way it it took a look at cultural
barriers and deconstructed them and
defuse them in the same way that get out
took a look at racial barriers and
stereotyping and diffused them and made
them accessible for people to like be
entertained by the film but also think
for a minute at what's really going on
that's an interesting answer I have a
specific question for you so you're
contending that Justice League should be
nominated for Best Visual Effects why do
you still contend that even though
Steppenwolf looks like a character from
the video game Doom well we don't know
that that wasn't their intent okay that
was your dog you want that argument
bringing it back all I'm saying is that
if you're an Olympic judge and you see a
sprinter complete a beat everyone by a
mile that's the big sick you'd be like
that guy won you see a gymnast perform
an entire routine with a broken leg
that's the Justice League and they do
okay
they stick the landings it's not pretty
but they finish it
that's the Justice League and I would
give that a gold medal okay we you each
have 30 seconds you're alone in a room
with an Academy a member with a sway the
Academy member to vote for your project
Academy members Academy Mirza listen me
how could you not nominate the big sick
this is a movie that people have been
talking about all year long from when it
got sold at Sundance to when it opened
over the summer to author award season
on home entertainment people were
laughing at the film they were watching
it over and over again they were they
were it was so well written it was so
well acted and and Ray Romano Holly
Hunter every performance across the
board was great and and commandant
Johnny who's on Silicon Valley
he established himself as a romantic
leading man and he wasn't just a regular
white dude I mean this was a movie that
really had a lot to say about
stereotyping and and cultural barriers
but it was funny it's quotable it's a
movie that you could watch over and over
and over again and appreciate it for all
these things
thank you sir you are alone with an
Academy memory sway them to vote for
Justice League for visual effects first
I'm gonna hand them a twenty and then
I'm gonna say they need to win you guys
like these are honest men and maybe also
women we're given jobs on this project I
don't know
honest men and women doing their best
earning an honest wage let something
good come from this horrible wrong give
them what they deserve time wow what a
battle the Justice League versus the big
sick Oscar snubs yes applause all around
Jenni when I heard you were gonna battle
for Justice League for visual effects I
thought that was an impossible task and
you proved me right even though you know
you tugged at my heartstrings but
they've given you the 20 you should have
given me the 20 that would have been a
bet no this is honest here but we you
don't you don't give Oscar nom for a
good try or like you know oh we knew you
had a tough job they were facing
adversity like the characters you made
your argument already yeah at the end of
the day your argument was for the
adversity they faced and that's true I
mean Zack Snyder tragedy befell him and
Joss Whedon had to come in and you know
what they did the best with what they
could and I'll tell you what Jenni you
get a win for making me appreciate the
job they had to do a little bit more but
Scott you laid out just point by point
from the cultural and social
significance to the humor - yeah just
the specifics of that 9/11 joke that
showed how much heart this film had the
fact that it could take us to laugh at
that and it did redesign it did give us
a new take on the rom-com
for all of those myriad reasons you laid
out I think the big snick the
SiC you've made a good case why it was
us the biggest snub and not too big
okay let's talk yeah here's what I'm
thinking
I I mean definitely points for
creativity for Jenny that's that's a
very strong answer Scott I was very
passionate I disagree a little bit I I'm
the 9/11 joke thing because I think the
Team America nine hundred and eleven
thousand like there's been jokes that
have addressed that that subject matter
that I found were you know able to do it
communist yeah I guess I'm a coming
after that maybe came out like two
thousand four two thousand four yeah so
it's not the first time but I but I see
the point and I see in a so it's I agree
though it's such an uphill battle for
Jenny to fight and so I feel like she
almost started at a disadvantage and by
choice yeah and when she you know when
she said that I'm like I don't know like
I I'm so torn that I feel like I should
throw it to the people and let the
people decide because it goes both ways
Scott was so passionate Virginia's was
so creative yeah that I'm gonna throw a
mic support to Jenny and we will let the
people decide this one Wow Wow
you know what he's so out of pace this
is how he feels
nothing's writing this toward um alright
going right now yeah thank you just are
going right now that's just work with
your friends they'll always support your
crappy jokes so as of right now I will
say this gap was huge at first and then
was closed in one person still one but
the other person battled so fiercely
that they went from like nothing to like
some numbers so the winner of this from
the people was the big stick for Best
Picture
but I gotta say Justice League special
effects you were winning people over
every time you opened your mouth it was
amazing I was watching it happen and I
was like can she do it can she do it can
she do it looking
some of the comments Benjy builder men
on Twitter says one thing is for sure
giorgo start needs a job where he laughs
over if she sitcoms and such that laugh
is contagious
hahaha and then no when Dean 27 said but
obviously the biggest snub is that the
two seconds of man's asking in such a 6
Shakespearean fashion what is knob come
on guys that's best actor material right
there oh thank you nice well Scott manse
you take the point we are locked up at
[Applause]
you know I want to send like an edible
arrangement to those editors now all
right you guys uh I hope you're ready
for [ __ ] to get nuts cause this is a
blind fight oh I don't know what's
happening yes there are but there are
there are things in here okay Jenny
would you pull the thing out of this one
don't look okay Scott will you pull the
thing out great all right Jenny what
does yours say watch what does yours say
50 shades darker all right you know I
get that way here's what's happening
y'all the Razzie nominations came out
this week and in the Hat was every movie
nominated for worst movie you have to
argue why the movie you chose should win
Best Picture
that's the horse picture right No Best
Picture wait wait wait I know what yeah
exactly
you're gonna have to take this crap
movie that was nominated for a Razzie
and flip the script
nah man and tell us why it should be
nominated for Best Picture at the Oscars
is your mind blown yet
easy this is worse than when I had to
argue against lala land I'm still
hurting all right you do you understand
the task at hand
do you understand the monumental task
ahead of you smash it yes again what's
your movie Scott fifty shades darker and
what's your movie Baywatch all right
thank you Jenny's got a first so first
No um it goes first round you go first
second round she goes first back around
to you for this damn it yes stop come ha
okay compose yourself and there are
great movies are great movies when it
comes to the Citizen Kane of great
movies fifty shades darker a movie about
instant passion an attraction people
cannot keep their hands off of each
other they love each other so much they
want to make love 24/7 they want to be
naked they want to use objects they
would never say bad dialogue and make it
sound really really good and it's so
convincing Dakota Johnson is this year's
Meryl Streep she carries that movie
she carries fifty shades darker fifty
times more powerful of an actress than
Meryl Streep is Dakota Johnson and the
guy what's his name what's his name
Christian Grey Jamie Dornan Jamie Dornan
my gosh eat your heart out Robert De
Niro that he could take dialog and
deliberately make it sound awful make it
sound awful and Newark chemistry the
movie is so that movie is it's so cheesy
and so bad that you laugh at it the fact
that you're taking a serious movie and
you're able to laugh at it is a sign
that the movie is transcending its
intentions and for that reason it
deserves to be Best Picture because
there's more to it than meets the eye
fifty shades darker is a story of
obsession a story of absolute fatal
attraction hold that thought any
Nicholson give us your opening salvo
all right well Baywatch is a tale of
heroism which we all know
really well at the Oscars it has an
all-star cast it mixes humor Zac Efron
is in it as well as Dwayne the rock
Johnson and at least three beautiful
women these men run around on a beach
saving people's lives as I said it's
held heroism and not only that an
adaptation of a cultural milestone yours
is also an adaptation but I think yours
really stumbled across the finish line
it only included one of the four
helicopter rides completely cut the set
a [ __ ] friend which was one of the key
story elements in the book so I think it
didn't do justice to what was a
wonderful story whereas mine takes an
already wonderful story and elevates it
and brings it to a whole new generation
fight it out disagree Jenny Nicholson
and here's why
you know they watch the TV show was
about heroism was it was it had a good
message to it the film the movie
Baywatch it was just a raunchy comedy
that did not capture the heart and the
goodwill and the inspiration of the show
that it was based on fifty shades darker
is an adaptation so of course you're not
gonna be able to film everything that's
in the book or else the movie would be
four hours long but what they captured
this but talk about movies that talk
about movies that the Academy loves how
about a love story Titanic was a love
story and up 111 Academy Awards fifty
shades darker it's the Titanic of SNM
movies well from my perspective from my
perspective any film that deserves to
win Best Picture
I would be more than happy to see it
before hours long so I think it's a
failure on the part of the filmmakers
that they were willing to cut out even a
moment of the story and I think to spit
in the face of one of the best literary
works of the past 50 years
it's just a disgrace baywatch brought
humor and wit and charm there are so
many teenagers that would never watch
the old series that love this Baywatch
film I got to disagree with that because
the movie did not do well domestically
it did okay overseas I think I made a
little over many sleeper hits that went
Oscar to
200 million dollars maybe a little more
I'm not I'll be fact-check on this but
but the movie did not capture what made
the TV series last for 10 years and
become a worldwide global phenomenon and
if the TV show was such a worldwide hit
but the movie was not that there is a
reason for that they are not making a
sequel to Baywatch and they are making
another movie after fifty shades darker
so obviously the movie is so strong so
powerful and did so well that it
warrants a third movie okay we are neck
and neck here I want each of you to
break down some of the additional Oscars
that your movie might be nominated for
and yeah Jenny let's start with you um
definitely both Best Actor and Best
Supporting Actor for Zefron and join the
rock Johnstone's who gets what who gets
what oh um Zac Efron is the supporting
character so he would win Best
Supporting Actor great guy yes yes
that's that's what their characters are
visual effects it's not gonna be Justice
League but it's nice to get the NAM they
had a lot of dangerous stunts and
definitely best score Best Original
Score sick okay
big sick so talk about this is good this
numbs fifty shades darker is going to
get more nominations than wallah lands
which tied with 14 nominations last year
and yes any excuse to bring up that
movie I will do it as you all know but
fifty shades darker first of all an
absolutely Best Picture Best Director
contender because it is a movie the
people that people embraced it did very
well was a movie for the masses and it
was it was a Best Adapted Screenplay
because it did a perfect job of taking
the core elements core elements Jenny
Nicholson the core elements forget about
that helicopter let it go it did a court
the great job of but why don't we get
down to the bare essentials to make it a
great movie talk about great score the
score touring the sex scenes maybe we
just want to go out and have sex right
away it was so enterica with that
careful with Getty because it showed
just enough but didn't go too far with
it and the best visual effects Jamie
Dornan
ABS Dan that's like
make us were real well how do you know
that maybe it was CGI talk about visual
effects talk about your below the line
tell about people who need to be
appreciated Janie Nicholson that should
have been your argument for the last one
all right uh time Wow
dan please fact-checked Jamie Dornan
zaps and Wow this this is a real tough E
right here you both I mean two uphill
battles and Scott you really came out
swinging calling it the Citizen Kane of
movies Citizen Kane the Citizen Kane the
cities of Kane of yeah okay but you
talked about the passion of the love
story and you talked about this film and
you had some good digs on Jenny and as
much as hers was just a raunchy movie
and didn't do well at the box office but
then you came back and you said it
doesn't have to be a box-office success
other arguments but Scott you did
something that pulled the rug out from
under yourself a little bit
you called it a cheesy bad movie that
transcended it so with that you were
kind of like in one foot in one foot out
it's it's a passionate love story you're
arguing a four and then it's like oh
it's an unintentional comedy Scott I'm
asking you which is it and but was that
enough for Jenny to take it Jenny you
came back with a story of heroism great
adaptation and it had a lot of charm and
because of you made enough arguments and
Scott you pulled the rug out from under
yourself in my eyes
I gotta go Jenny Nicholson on this one
Baywatch don't pay watch how I'm going
the other way although Scott did have
one factual error there was a big watch
sequel and now it's prior to the opening
the current Baywatch
that has not yet been taken off the
table you forgot the part how though
where Scott said and this is one of my
favorite new phrases about any movie
that fifty shades darker transcended its
intentions and I felt like the part that
you dinged him for was almost his way of
praising the film for transcending what
it could have been even further I
thought that he was very good at
deflecting Jenny's adaptation issues
fifty-six darkish the Titanic of S&M
movies I mean that great line that's a
box quote if ever I heard so I am
actually gonna go I felt from Jenny's
arguments that that her reasoning was
really just that she knew to cast
members and that it was based on
Baywatch I haven't even seen the trailer
of the Baywatch film I get to go with
Scott on this one i voting mance oh we
are locked up at one one Danielle let's
go to the YouTube votes to break this
time that means the people get a vote
yeah yeah okay well in this case um you
know they just fifty shades darker with
30 percent Baywatch had sixty nine
[Music]
argument seemed to be a real clincher
for you I will say one thing a lot of
people were wondering about online yes
if Scott mentions Long Island or citizen
McCain we do still take a shot it can
just be like fruit juice or like a
Lacroix or something I like a
Pamplemousse myself what's a half of
Twitter was Chris movie corner said have
to say it Jenny and Nicholson is one of
the most eloquent book ever what a
fighter Wow Wow nicely done nicely done
Danielle follow-up question have the
memes been dank the memes have been dank
[Applause]
like some sexy Flanders we're doing real
good hell yeah
Thank You Danielle and thank you guys
for voting Wow Jenny we are headed into
speed
you're holding a 2-1 lead over movie
manse Scott please quit living in the
past and get ready for the speed round
okay so here's dem rules of the speed
round though so the first person to get
four points wins Jenny is up two to one
there are seven total questions for on
the speed round here so first person to
for Jenny is up to 2-1 and your internet
vote there's not enough time for that
right now so Danielle will just weigh in
to break any ties or maybe we'll switch
it up and Dan will break the tire I'll
break the tie Oh
but yeah ooh I will still be monitoring
your stuff but no more polls heck yeah
all right competitors yes so you each
get 20 seconds and then 10-second
rebuttals the first person to speak will
go first okay the first person to answer
will go first are you ready ready ready
ready
Jack I'm ready ready Jenny question one
Jurassic world is getting its own live
arena show joining Fast and the Furious
live what other movie franchise should
inspire a live stunt or fifty shades
darker okay Jenny says fifty shades
Justice League okay you do realize you
could have said something that wasn't
talked about on the show today I'm sorry
it was the first thing human brain oh
great answers or the great answers all
right Jenny there's 20 seconds on the
clock for you time begins when you speak
mm-hmm this would be a permanent show
set in Vegas it's great for bachelorette
parties it's an adult's arena show they
can also use puppets just like the
jurassic world one they're just large
grotesque puppets of nude human bodies
having BDSM intercourse that's my entire
point
that's my god it's gonna keep going okay
we can have a live band as well great
thank you Scott whenever you're ready I
see I see Justice League on ice it's
gonna be just asleep meets I Tanya and
it's going to be superheroes are nice
it's going to be a great show they're
gonna have lavish costumes incredible
triple axels
and it's gonna be fun for the whole
family grown-ups and kids will love
Justice League on ice a live show that
will be fun and exciting and
entertaining and they'll have villains
all right ten second rebuttal okay like
the spider-man movie I see or musical I
see people getting hurt at your Ice Show
a lot of dangerous stunts mine is just
fun for the whole family you know
everybody loves superheroes Justice
League didn't do vials a movie it'll do
better as a as a live show especially if
it's on ice and fifty shades darker as a
live show I mean like why do a live show
why not just take it to the bedroom
doing time
Wow two interesting shows yes two
interesting answers you know what let's
start with Danielle Radford give us your
thoughts they were both really
compelling but just the idea of I want
to see like that combination of Avenue Q
and Fifty Shades that Jenny was
promising me and so I got to go with
Jenny yeah that's one for Jenny Dan I
wonder though because she talked about
the puppets having intercourse but then
she said it was fun for the whole family
they're puppets
I don't I still don't know if that's
exactly fun for the whole family in an
avian country sometimes they teach like
I don't know I just felt like Scott had
the stunt show I felt like that was just
water one I know only a woman understand
Jenny said fun for the whole family and
you know what she also said though it
would be great for bachelorette parties
and those those shows in Vegas those
adulty kind of shows like the Thunder
from Down Under or like they're the
long-running what was the name of
everything Spears yeah
Brittany's beard no there was like some
like like 10 years ago I went to some
weird
Oh the show
called Jubilee at Bally's where it was
like unexpectedly all like everyone was
topless who's so weird
but you so that was a good point I could
see Fifty Shades being up being a
Bachelorette
oriented show and Scott like you didn't
really ding her on anything but she
dinged you saying would be like
spider-man turned off the dark and
people would get hurt so because of her
total argument I gotta go Jenny
everyone you're a great fighter 3-1 it
is 3 1 and if Jenny takes this point she
wins Scott you need this to continue the
game right you need this to continue the
game well crusher alright here's the
question Ryan Reynolds will be taking on
a clue remake for Fox which board game
would best work as a feature film
monopoly I'm going don't wake daddy okay
we have monopoly we have don't wake
daddy Scott your time start by you know
nah Polly you can have someone like
Ridley Scott who was in talks to direct
monopoly installed a little bit but he's
still the perfect person for the job
obviously it's good enough that someone
was actually considering it but this is
a movie that is very timely and relevant
now it is it is a it is a game that
everybody knows around the world it's
one of the most famous board games of
all time the story about real estate I'm
Jenny
don't wake daddy I'm getting Guillermo
del Toro it's going to be set in a dark
fantasy universe where the children are
creeping around this massive scaled
bedroom and daddys like an eldritch
abomination monster rendered in
horrifying CGI and they need to get out
of the bedroom before daddy wakes and
devours them all it's a horrifying but
it also works for children all the
protagonists are kids time okay don't
wake daddy that doesn't sound like
there's enough there to warrant a whole
movie you're taking an idea not a whole
concept flushing out a story you know my
movie monopoly you have the big mogul
played by Michael Douglas time I feel
monopoly would have trouble finding an
audience because it sounds like an
adult-oriented story set to the theme of
a children's game whereas don't like
daddy is a horror movie you can get the
teens you can also get the adults that
like del Toro's work-time Wow
what a battle dan Morell it's good to
you I think Jenny clearly had the more
fleshed out pitch just the director and
a name I think that I would have to go
with Jenny Lee
yep Danielle oh god yeah manse I love
you but don't wake daddy sounds like
something I definitely want to go see
she had an idea she again she had she
had a way that knew would subvert the
original board game and so people
wouldn't just go in being like oh it's
the don't wake daddy game
she had a director she had everything a
guy just I got a couple Jenny on this
one it was too strong my boat don't
matter because Jenny said wow that was
very him like I was like damn she is
painting a vivid picture right now board
games yeah
you guys that was so much fun Congrats
Jenny Nicholson for taking the day Scott
mance you know we still love ya uh Dan
Moreau thank you for holding it down on
the facts sir yes uh thoughts non
sequiturs anything at all what do you
want what do you got it's great it's
it's a great to see these two match up
against each other I thought it was a
very fun fight it's a good clean fight
but very passionate and I hope that
everyone at home enjoyed it watching it
as much as we did here in the studio
what you think of all Scott manse is
cussing more cussing than I'm used to
from the heart today yeah I did white up
having to tone down my own costing just
to make sure cuz your cussing is the
most important cause saying - just like
ancillary yeah we love your custom
contestants get first class I can I can
I can push it back
Danielle anything to plug anything else
to say to the folks out there um y'all
can see me here all of the time thank
you so much this was just such a really
fun fight
I made a great time both of these
competitors were massive I can't wait to
see them back hell yeah
Jenny Nicholson our champion please plug
some stuff and say hi to everybody I
have a YouTube channel it's
to my name it's Jenny Nicholson and I
talk about it on my Twitter that's on
this and that's about it
that's what I got to plug heck yeah
Scott mance always a pleasure to have
you my biological father I'll see you at
the Passover Seder yes you can follow me
on twitter at movie manse you can follow
me on instagram at movie manse and
please follow me cuz you know I like to
tweet a lot it's all good
heck yeah I want to thank Billy and JT
and the booth and the whole screen
junkies clan for hanging out I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at Hal running and thanks for
watching movie fights
[Music]
you